I think we can all agree that fighter jets
are pretty sweet.
But sweet as they are, almost all of them
still lack one amazing feature of their whirlygig
helicopter cousins; the ability to hover.
Come on, it’s 2017 people, where are the
hovering jets?
The problem is a fundamental one.
You can think of the rotors of a helicopter
as wings.
They’re constantly moving through the air,
generating lift, even when the chopper is
hovering in place.
But jets, with their airfoils fixed in place,
need to keep moving forward.
If they don’t go fast enough their wings
don’t generate enough lift, and the jet
is essentially a very expensive rock.
But there is a way around this.
Why bother using the wings at all?
Heck you’ve got a mighty jet engine underneath
you, just point it at the ground and blast
off!
Over the years engineers have tried a few
different approaches, but the most successful
idea was to use thrust vectoring, like on
the Boeing AV-8B Harrier II.
The Harrier’s engine has four nozzles that
can swivel.
They can be pointed downward for vertical
takeoff, landing, and hovering.
Or they can be pointed backwards, and the
Harrier flies like any other jet.
That doesn’t mean all the problems are solved.
Unlike a helicopter, whose spinning blades
act like a gyroscope and stabilize it, a hovering
Harrier has to be balanced on its thrust,
which is no easy feat.
Worse, since there’s no air passing over
the wings, the normal control surfaces are
useless.
Cleverly, the Harrier sends compressed air
from its engine out of the nose, tail, and
wingtips so the pilot can still control the
aircraft while in a hover.
The next generation of fighter, the F-35B,
will also have the ability to hover using
its thrust-vectored jet engine and a giant
fan tucked behind the pilot.
But because of the engineering challenge and
the skill needed to fly them, it’s no surprise
that hovering jets are the exception, not
the norm.
For more epic stories of innovation that shaped
our future, check out TheAgeOfAerospace.com
If you liked this video, subscribe to the
channel, there's always more videos.
Like on helicopters! If you're more curious about that, Amy's got a video right here.
So important question: Which is cooler, jets
or helicopters?
Tell us down below and thanks for watching
Seeker.